[Música]
bienvenidos a este espacio dedicado al
medio ambiente en france 24 que una
semana más llega desde casa
esta emisión se la dedicamos por
completo a los ganadores del premio
goldman el más importante del mundo
otorgado a activistas ambientales estos
son los seis recipientes del galardón de
este año que fue entregado de manera
virtual el 30 de noviembre entre ellos
hay dos latinoamericanas y una francesa
comenzamos en mexico con lady page
apicultura indígena en maya que logró
detener la siembra de soya genéticamente
modificada por parte de la compañía
monsanto en varios estados del país
leidy ha luchado durante casi 10 años
contra los pesticidas y los transgénicos
en el estado de campeche en la península
del yucatán esta región es responsable
del 40 por ciento de la producción de
miel de mexico que a su vez es el sexto
productor mundial de esta sustancia una
lucha que le valió el apodo de guardiana
de las abejas o dama de la miel la
gigante monsanto famosa por su
producción y uso del polémico herbicida
glifosato
a sembrar soya en 2012 al recibir
permiso del gobierno mexicano en
respuesta se creó una coalición llamada
sin transgénicos que demandó al
ejecutivo y exigió detener este cultivo
ya que en ningún momento habían
consultado a la población local algo que
va en contra de la constitución mexicana
y también en contra de leyes
internacionales el trabajo de esta
coalición resultó en 2017 en la
revocación de permisos de cultivos
transgénicos monsanto en 7 estados del
país
de mexico vamos a ecuador de mountain en
quimo indígena huaorani fue la cara
visible de una campaña en contra de 16
concesiones petroleras que el gobierno
de ecuador quería ofrecer para atraer
inversión multinacional estas
concesiones afectaban a casi 3 millones
de hectáreas de territorios amazónicos
tras conocer la decisión del ejecutivo
de su país de monte lideró la campaña
nuestra selva no se vende que logró unas
400 mil firmas en el mundo finalmente el
caso llegó a los tribunales donde esta
líder ambiental
interpuso una demanda contra el gobierno
de ecuador por violar el derecho
huaorani al consentimiento libre previo
e informado
en abril de 2019 la justicia falló a
favor de la comunidad waorani una
decisión que ayudó a proteger de la
extracción petrolera más de 200.000
hectáreas de selva amazónica y que
también sentó un precedente legal para
los derechos indígenas en ecuador otra
de las mujeres ganadoras del premio es
la francesa louis y pensó el activismo
de esta joven llegó desde la gran ciudad
y se centró en el sector financiero la
proliferación de minas y de proyectos de
carbón en el mundo necesitan de
financiamiento y de recursos así que
luisi decidió enfocar sus esfuerzos en
los grandes bancos y en las empresas que
entregan dinero o que aseguran los
proyectos que dan continuidad al carbón
como la principal fuente de energía del
mundo y que es responsable del 46 por
ciento de las emisiones de co2 globales
a través de campañas de presión hacia
estas instituciones financieras y
exigiéndoles que se hagan responsable
del daño ambiental que crean sus
negocios
con la industria del carbón consiguió en
2019 que los tres mayores grupos
financieros y dos aseguradoras francesas
se comprometieran a no estar ligadas con
nuevos proyectos carboneros unas
acciones que ponen más presión sobre el
resto de entidades financieras que no
quieren quedarse atrás en la lucha
contra el cambio climático pasamos ahora
a la mujer que se llevó el premio que
representa a las naciones insulares por
primera vez las islas bahamas son
premiadas con un gol man y éste llegó de
la mano del trabajo de cristal
ambrós cristal consiguió que el gobierno
de las bahamas prohibiera a partir de
enero de 2020 el uso de plásticos de un
solo uso y del poliestireno expandido
conocido como icopor en colombia' unicel
en méxico o telgopor en argentina su
activismo sobre todo enfocado en el
poder de los jóvenes llegó mientras
trabajaba en el acuario de bahamas donde
vio de primera mano los estragos que el
plástico tiene en la fauna marina a
través de la educación pretende que los
habitantes de bahamas no sigan
contribuyendo a la contaminación causada
los plásticos de usar y botar que
constituyen un tercio de todo el
plástico producido en el planeta
dos de los seis premiados son hombres y
uno de ellos es pol shine
del pueblo karen en mianmar su activismo
se centra en proteger tanto la cultura
como el entorno natural de su etnia y en
2018 consiguió que se creara una zona
protegida de más de 545.000 hectáreas en
la cuenca del río salween bajo
administración del pueblo karen la
delimitación de esta área se hizo de
manera que incluyera zonas antes
concedidas a la construcción de presas
hidroeléctricas que hubieran tenido un
grave impacto ambiental en una región
muy rica en biodiversidad y que es de
las pocas zonas vírgenes que quedan en
el sudeste asiático y el sexto receptor
del premio goldman 2020 fue si ves de
ezequiel de gana este país depende en su
mayoría de la electricidad generada por
plantas hidroeléctricas sin embargo una
sequía cada vez más grave ha hecho que
esta industria no sea tan confiable el
gobierno ghanés puso entonces su mirada
en el carbón como una solución a la
escasez de suministro eléctrico en el
país sin embargo chaves desde que el
conocía los impactos
y sanitarios que esta forma de
producción energética tiene así que se
embarcó en una campaña de educación con
las comunidades que hubieran resultado
afectadas tras cuatro años de trabajo
social consiguió que el gobierno ghanés
cancelará la construcción de la que
hubiera sido la primera planta de carbón
del país y de un puerto adjunto que
hubiera permitido su importación ya que
ghana no produce este material los
premios goldman son considerados los
nobel de medio ambiente y en 2020
cumplían su edición 31 los perfiles de
los seis galardonados de este año
demuestran que los cambios reales llegan
desde acciones pequeñas e individuales y
que el poder al final si reside en el
pueblo es todo por esta semana los dejo
con imágenes de estos seis defensores
del planeta hasta la próxima